هذه ليست الإجابة التي تريد سماعها
عندما يُسأل وزير الخارجية عما إذا كان تنظيم الدولة
يكتسب قوة ،
إنه أمر معقد ، فهناك بالتأكيد
أماكن يكون فيها تنظيم الدولة أكثر قوة اليوم
مما كانت عليه قبل ثلاث أو أربع سنوات ،
لكن الخلافة ذهبت
هذا بالطبع بعد  يكشف تقرير البنتاغون
أن الجماعة الإرهابية
تعاود الظهور فعليًا في سوريا وأن نجم روبرت سي إن إن العراقي ينضم
إلينا الآن على الهواء مباشرة من البنتاغون ، لذا قال
باربرا الرئيس إن
داعش هزم التقرير رغم أنه
يبدو أنه يختلف ، نعم ، ليس هذا كثيرًا.
أعتقد أنه في
الأشهر الأخيرة قد اعترف
عندما قال أنه هُزم بنسبة 100 في المائة ، فإنه
يعني أن الأرض المادية
التي كانت تسيطر عليها داعش في السابق عبر
العراق وسوريا
ليست الآن تحت سيطرتهم إلى حد كبير ، لكن
جيوب داعش تعود إلى الظهور ،
فلديها تمويل مالي ووفقًا
وقدرة  لتنفيذ هجمات كما
رأينا وفقًا لآخر
التقديرات ، قد يكون هناك ما يقرب
من 15000 من
أتباع داعش و  المقاتلون الآن في العراق
وسوريا
يستمعون إلى المزيد قليلاً عن كيف
أوضح وزير الخارجية بومبيو كل هذا
وقد أصبحت قدرتهم على شن
هجمات خارجية أكثر صعوبة ، لقد قمنا
بإزالة
مخاطر كبيرة ليس كلها ولكن
قدر كبير
لذلك لديهم بعض القدرة على تمويل معدات
القطارات وما زالوا ينفذون الهجمات
وهناك المزيد حتى أن هناك ما يقرب من 70
ألف شخص
في مخيمات النازحين داخل سوريا
سبعون ألفًا وخمسون ألفًا
دون سن الثامنة
عشرة وهذا يصبح أرضًا خصبة جديدة
أرض التجنيد الجديدة لداعش
هي جيل جديد من مقاتلي تنظيم الدولة ،
لذا بربارة أيضًا فيما يتعلق
بسحب الرئيس القوات من سوريا ،
كم من العوامل أنه في
استعادة داعش للسلطة ، تعلم جيدًا الآن أن
هناك حوالي ألف جندي
أمريكي متبقي في
سوريا وهكذا هذا  يعني أن قوات الأمن
التي
دربوها هناك قد تكون
أكثر ضعفاً قليلاً وتكافح قليلاً للرد
ضد داعش في ذلك  المنطقة وعندما
يرى داعش ضعفًا
، فهذا عندما يتعلق الأمر بالجبهة